le salut à 3 doit désormais un symbole
de résistance en birmanie chaque jour
depuis le 6 février des milliers de
personnes manifestent pour protester
contre la prise de pouvoir de la junte
militaire le 1er février dernier l'armée
renverse le gouvernement
la dirigeante union succi est arrêté
mettant fin à une période de dix ans de
transition politique
la birmanie vite alors son quatrième
coup d'état depuis 1962 mais cette fois
ci le rejet de la population prend des
proportions plus élevées car malgré une
répression sanglante de l'armée
la population est déterminé et se
mobilisent passer dans la clandestinité
des opposants décident de former leur
propre gouvernement soutenait le
gouvernement d'unité nationale pour
l'avenir de nos enfants
seul le peuple peut décider seul le
peuple prendra part à la bataille finale
je crois en notre victoire la
contestation doit réussir
les réseaux sociaux permettent une
meilleure organisation de cette
désobéissance civile des milliers de
travailleurs se mettent en grève
paralysant des pans entiers de
l'économie discours déclaration
malgré les appels de la population la
communauté internationale ne réagit que
timidement les états unis décident de
suspendre tout engagement commercial
l'union européenne elle met en place des
sanctions financières
l'asian association des nations de
l'asie du sud-est appelle de son côté
les militaires à cesser les violences
les prisonniers politiques doivent être
libérés immédiatement et il est
important de nommer des envoyés spéciaux
de la zenn composée du secrétaire
général et du président de la zenn afin
d'encourager le dialogue avec toutes les
parties concernées birmanie le rhénus de
son côté a appelé la junte ce vendredi à
appliquer le plan de l'asian
l'organisation craint que la crise ne se
mue en conflit de grande ampleur et
durable
l'image de la syrie depuis trois mois la
répression a tué près de 760 civils
selon l'association d'assistance aux
prisonniers politiques
des milliers de personnes 3500 selon les
différentes estimations ont été arrêtées
et parmi elles de nombreux portées
disparues